[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui ben au
moins plus de 60 ans de carrière c'est
probablement l'artiste vivant dont
l'oeuvre est la plus immédiatement
reconnaissable par le grand public
une grande exposition être libre lui est
consacrée au domaine de chamarande dans
l'essonne jusqu'au 11 octobre
je reçois également duplex tom connor 24
ans est l'un des benjamins de cette
rentrée littéraire il publie radical
chez albin michel un roman sur la
radicalisation d'un étudiant à l'extrême
droite dans la france d' emmanuel macron
on en parlera dans la seconde partie de
l'émission
et on commence tout de suite par notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de 21e siècle a parlé masquer la
peur du corona virus
la réponse en images on commence par
l'image de ben votre image à vous c'est
une carte une carte du monde
ah oui alors pour moi j'avais voulu
avoir une règle et bois je fais des
frontières de demander une carte pour
demander les acides et les nations comme
elle entre les frontières tracées par
l'impérialisme mais en réalité si on
prend l'idée des peuples on s'aperçoit
que dans telle région il y ait des
peuples des peuples qui ont une langue
une culture une histoire et qu' elle ne
figure pas dans moi j'aurais voulu le
faire la carte du monde avec des langues
des cultures et des peuples
par exemple chez hm plant la france
seulement nous avons des bleus temps
mais il est pas le breton nous avons des
corps est ce qu'on va le corse rien à
quoi on bat elles sont donc on peut le
faire
moi je verrais bien une europe des
nations mais une europe des peuples et
des peuples comme a conduit le peuple je
dis qu'est ce qu'il entend pas peuple
moi quand on me dit le mot peuple
j'entends par peuple une langue une
culture surtout une langue une culture
un passé quelque chose qui fonctionne
c'est en dehors je sais pas si j'ai dit
que j'avais voulu voir une europe et des
signes à l'europe et des langues et des
cultures et les peuples se réunissaient
je venais en europe
mais si c'est une europe des
impérialistes qui disent ah moi je
procède ce s'image procès de cela c'est
moi qui décide c'est moi qui
là j'ai pas tellement pour voilà donc on
peut passer à l'aube aux prochaines qui
tombe bien cette caste holmes conan vous
votre image la voici
c'est une vitrine des citoyens et finale
pourquoi celle-ci alors en fait c'est
une photo que qui a été prise que j'ai
prise à cherbourg il ya quelques
semaines ou en fait j'ai constaté qu'il
y avait la quasi totalité des commerces
qui était en train de fermer à la suite
bomba delà de la pandémie
mais au-delà de l'aspect un peu
conjoncturelle je me suis rappelé est
rendu compte que c'était aussi la fin
d'une époque c'est tout simplement la
fin d'un monde le monde du retail le
monde de la vente directe de la vente
physique on pourrait dire moi je me sens
quand même qu'il va y avoir une sorte de
généralisation voilà global de la vente
digitale et des relations digital en
général donc je pense que ça lui ce très
bien faire c'est vraiment une
liquidation totale un peu comme si le
philosophe slovène slavoj zizek
il parle souvent de la liquidation
totale il est toujours fasciné par cette
espèce de l'expression très très brutal
d'anéantissement qui sont utilisés en
france parce que c'est pas forcément le
cas dans d'autres pays donc là je crois
que voilà ça symbolise est pas mal ce
qui se passe actuellement et en
particulier en france sur ce campus la
phrase on voit bien déstockage finale
elle répété quatre fois aucun vraiment
n'aurait pu y compris que c'est vraiment
absolument total c'est une annie llense
annihilation déstockage finale commence
avec marcel duchamp oui l emporte
bouteille c'est le déstockage final je
la fais ton prochain
en fin de compte est possible dans le
tout possible de de duchamp qui est on
peut le trouver là dedans une fois au
musée c'est le tout possible en art donc
c'est possible c'est je le comprends ce
déstockage finale
même le sont pas au point de vue maladie
peu comme on vous retrouve dans la
deuxième partie de l'émission pour
parler de votre roman ça va ronfler a
tout de suite commencé avec ben et son
oeuvre
[Musique]
ben vous êtes certainement le l'artiste
dont l'oeuvre est la plus immédiatement
reconnaissable par les grands véhicules
grand public ce sont vos c'est votre
écriture on la voit là d'ailleurs elle
figure sur la fiche de cette exposition
qui se tient jusqu'au jusqu'au 11
octobre
cette écriture c'est vraiment la vôtre
encore aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la
mienne écoutez je vous raconte un peu le
début il y avait une exposition de
groupe dans lequel chaque artiste est
venu ils avaient exposé leurs oeuvres
qu'ils voulaient briser en m'a dit tiens
ta place et les lacs est ce que tu vas m
et moi je me suis demandé qu'est ce que
je veux bien mettre la place j'ai mis le
gall des mois ne regardais pas les
autres
c'est un message simple je les écris
donc à partir de là je pouffe lui aussi
ait pu écrire regarder ailleurs j'ai
aussi des musulmans tableau tableau 45
centimes et blanc donc je me suis dit je
veux me spécialiser dans la vérité des
vérités objectives de vérité subjective
c'est le temps avec le temps je
m'appelle soit d'une chose qui était
important c'est que je contiens du du
sens dans mes excuses peut poser des
questions politiques je peux poser des
questions philosophiques je peux me
poser des questions qu'est-ce que je
suis beau koala la cua ciel là je peux
me questionner tandis que quelqu'un qui
peint des arabes ou des quelqu'un qui
fait un script du combinat venait ou
buren qui veut des bandes et les îles
ces sondes et des cônes atteint une fois
que ce n'est que des décorateurs je suis
le seul qui n'est pas un qui ne soit pas
un décorateur seulement leur pose des
questions pour morale là je ne pose pas
là je fais une affirmation
pour moi elle est beaucoup de critiques
d'art sont des artistes refoulés pour
moi vous êtes le seul artiste qui soit
un critique d'art reflets c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien que la plupart de vos
oeuvres et notamment celles où genzyme
au son des explications pratiques de ce
qu'est l'art où j'accepte pour votre
point de vue là je trouve que par
exemple les idoles à un seul mais c'est
un moment donné je me dis mais je suis
seul à talons dans le jeu les cris je
suit les digues d'avant des artistes
peut-être oui je me pose des questions
sur la en tant que ville d'art et je
trouve que sa cible ça c'est assez
positif puisque tous les autres font de
la belle débuts en scène cela j'en doute
un de mes mollets importance et je doute
moi même ce jeu duch
il me permet de penser et je pense pas
que à ego basse et dans une expo est ce
qu'on veut me voir ce que je vais dire à
la fiac est ce que je vais apprécier ce
que je vais être là non
les questions que je me pose peuvent
m'amener dans la politique
internationale peut m'amener dans la
politique culturelle peut m'amener à me
poser beaucoup de questions donc
artistes qui se posent des questions
tant que roda est plus important qu'un
artiste qui ne fait que des cacas par
exemple cette phrase là pour moi elle
résume totalement votre votre art c j'ai
voulu abandonner l'armée j'en ai fait de
l'art en fait vous avez voulu aborder
dollar parce que vous aviez compris
comment ça fonctionnait quand vous
commencez à vous emparer de la banane et
que vous mettez des balades partout vous
avez compris que la banane ça pourrait
dans l'histoire des jeux chez une femme
que les autres n'avaient pas fait je
m'étais dit ça il ya polyakov qu'il a
fait ça soulage daffé sable comme l'a
fait celui ci a fait alors et je dois la
banane personnes avaient la banane
j'étais content et j'ai dit je suis le
roi de la banane à ce moment là yves
klein me dit ban les balancer fini
c'est pourquoi il me dit pas ce que le
mot locaux un plus fort que la banane du
comment c'est comme au poker il me dit
qu monochrome c4as la banane cccb
houssin floch voilà donc je me suis
abandonnée la banane et je devenir le
roi de la banane et du pain des bananes
je l'étais vraiment minable et j'ai
aussi poser des questions et donc j'ai
voulu abandonner là mais j'en ai fait de
l'art seul je crois que c'est vrai c'est
vrai aussi mais ce prix pourrait vous
demande
oui vous avez un moment signé les gens
de la rue sage tresse est très marrant
après marcel duchamp qui avait signé
louis noël il y avait il n'y avait même
s'il y avait une journée c'est ce que et
manzoni avait fait les sculptures
vivantes des gens sur un socle donné que
moi j'ai acheté des clochards et je me
demandais ce que tu maîtrises de cet htc
22 cents lots et une deuxième à ce que
vivent donc j'avais acheté des clochards
écoutez là on va faire de l'histoire de
l'art j'en ai marre l'histoire de l'art
il faut avancer ses moyens je signais
des clochards le temps que roda là vous
allez me ramener à mon histoire moi ben
hassine les crochets bah oui
les miroirs les sculptures vivantes la
vérité la vérité est important n'importe
quoi ça c'est important
les accidents catastrophe aussi c'était
pas mal je m'étais les personnes
assignées les catastrophes gestion des
catastrophes
au fond ce que vous nous rappeler ces
quatre artistes et signé non être
considérés non non non non non être
artiste est un égoïste être négocié stss
et rejoint ma nouvelle théorie que l'ego
est très important quand je regarde les
films à la télé sur les animaux sur les
sages les jeux les coléoptères et les
plantules chose je m'aperçois que tout
ce qui est vivant contient de lego parce
que tout ce qu'ils vivent on vous
cherche se reproduire et tout ce qu'ils
cherchent à se reproduire contient du
code contient de lego dans ma tour
illégaux ces essais et essai s est
agrandi là mais qu'une petite partie de
la tuerie de lego lego de bénac des
artistes c'est d'une petite chose
l'ego des nationalistes légaux des
présidents dès que le maquereau l'égard
de madame de madame de trempe légaux
d'ici et on s'aperçoit que le monde des
fables et kiko dgo dgo vous en avez fait
une théorie de lego qui est devenu un
livre d'ailleurs on va voir la création
et de l'ego d'ailleurs j'aime bien
keolis de lego voilà il ya le livre
torride les gauchers fabre mais parfois
je me demande si vous ne confondez pas
le style des artistes qui est forcément
singulier le style de rembrandt le style
de chaque classe style voilà chacun
songe comme son style c'est lui sa
vision du monde est ce que vous ne
confondez pas avec lego au fond la
manière de peindre de rembrandt ça n'est
pas son ego y en avait sans doute mais
ça ne peut pas prévu mais sa a6 fives
non non chaque attise dès qu'il a trouvé
son truc c'est son ego si l'ambulance et
du clair obscur c'est son truc
si l'autre c'est les femmes nues un peu
grosse c'est son truc
chacun sent plus le noir the soulage ses
aînés juin soulage qui combat avec atom
qui ce combat avec ceux ci les noirs
différents camps vont en ce moment j'ai
fait d'un tableau que j'expose chez
guipy d'elle c'est le mont noir écrit
mille fois différent avec des noix
différents
et c'est nul c'est pas bon parce que ce
n'est que encore de la décollation je
fini par tomber dans le dans la
décollation moi qui voulait quitter la
décollation pour l'interrogation pour la
suite
pour continuer là pour faire avancer la
juste un peu plus loin elle n'arrive pas
mais par contre c'est pour ça que j'y
tiens à revenir à la politique
internationale parce que en pensant à la
je me suis retrouvé en train de france
et la psychiatrie la psychiatrie je
pense à lego lego je pense à ma famille
que je me dispute avec ma femme et tout
ça et là disputé avec ma femme devient
élevé relation directe avec avec avec
les disputée entre les nations parce que
c'est le même ego le même ego kiala et
les tentes les nations tout ce qui se
passe en biélorussie aujourd'hui ce qui
se passa au nucléaire ou julie ce qui se
passe partout
c'est encore des histoires d'ego et et
moi je croyais que c'est des choses
différentes par exemple la cuisine mais
la cuisine de ma femme quand elle fait
sa cuisine à elle c'est encore une
histoire d'ego puisqu'elle vient me dit
tu comprend une juge a donc c'est cette
théorie de lego j'ai réussi à la case
est partout ben est ce que vous voyez
comme un grand artiste un bon artiste ou
un mauvais artistes en temps critique
d'art pas vous voulez me voir comme
artisanale et voulait me voir comme
rupteur un rupteur bout - il ya eu john
cage comme l'uptr il a mis les mains sur
le piano il a fait 15 minutes 55 du
silence joe du champ il appuie importe
bouteille la signer c'est une des
rupteurs c'est pas des variétés et moi
j'ai voulu être un rupteur mais en quoi
parce que j'ai une grande tango donc il
aurait fallu que je me suicide peut-être
ou quelque chose comme ça d'autres ont
fermé d'autres ont fait court mais je
voyais ça avance comme ça le schmilblick
est ce que quand vous signez d'état ou
vous signez des clochards
est-ce que vous avez l'impression de
faire le même travail que rambo quand
j'ai signé quoi d'état d'état un an
signé d tat et allaoui a pas que moi qui
signait des benêts qui fait dix-sept
états mais moi je suis jamais moi
quand je balaye parce que j'avais balayé
et quand ma femme en gueule que je
balaye un peu jeudi m but even fait
volta j'étais content de mon état
mais a pas d'autres tâches vois pas
d'autres taxes je fais ça tu vas
formellement quand vous avez signé tout
et n'importe quoi est ce que vous aviez
l'impression à ce moment là d'être un
artiste
après rembrandt et de faire la même
chose que rambo où elle sera une
pression j'avais l'impression essayé de
passer sur un territoire
j'avais l'impression de me dit bon
écoute et il y avait une bande de jeunes
qui étaient allemands d'un côté et tu
avais dit les accumulations c'est moi
les gars c'est amuser les compétitions
c'est moi yves klein disait ne touchez
pas le morro comme c'est moi je gagnais
à peine j'ai compris de jeu j'ai dit je
prends un dictionnaire je l'ouvrais
n'importe quelle page
je mets la main dessus et je disais moi
je la fais c'est moi et donc c'est elle
est toujours légaux parce qu'on était
dans ce combat d'ego entre artistes et
il ne croyait pas que il y avait des
impressionnistes qui s'en sortait pas
non soto c'est égoïste à tous y compris
les sait qu'ils vont dans leur mental
peindre soi disant pour le tout seul et
que personne morale devant voir le
tableau des égoïstes mais reconnaissez
je le deviens ego tour des scènes
pendant longtemps larissa a consisté à
inventer de la beauté qui n'existaient
pas vous vous parlez d'une période où
tout à coup chacun veut sa blessure il
existe encore et hamon était une bêtise
monsieur tony de la beauté déjà la
beauté c'est comme si ça existait
n'existait pas non et les artistes
apportent quelque chose de nouveau dans
le champ de ce qu'on appelle la culture
est dans le champ du l'abstraction dans
le champ du débat l'exemple aujourd'hui
dans le champ de
du style tap
il apporte quelque chose alors il y en a
quelques-uns alors c'est là que j'ai
commencé à m'interroger sur moi-même
avec quelques-uns qui apporte quelque
chose parce qu'ils ont quelque chose à
l'intérieur par exemple je dirais que
bastia où certains artistes qui aurait
dû dire non après la figuration ne peut
plus faire la figuration sont venus à
faire des choses parce qu'ils avaient en
eux mêmes donc là je deviens un amateur
de l'art singulier et je deviens
d'amateurs de de la maison rouge et je
deviens d'amateurs de quelqu'un du fou
le paranoïaque ou bipolaires
geep pas s'empêcher de peindre lui même
ce qu'il fait donc dix ans que healy à
l'histoire de l'art ou angers genevois
après l'autre cha cha cha cha cha en
tuant tous les nouveaux et puis il y a
de singulier qui est singulier lui même
sens qu'ils n'arrivent pas à rien jeter
comme le facteur cheval qui n'arrive pas
à être le même donc là singulier existe
mais ensuite
attention il ya des ethnies les peuples
j'ai le mien mais peuple tout le temps
les dogons gens leur art avec leurs
nouveautés avec leur novateur il y avait
avec leurs quêtes et les lits les écoute
ils ont leur art aussi avec leur
créativité l on l'a jamais glisser la
phrase de claude lévi-strauss deux dans
chaque n'ya pas de peuple sans sa langue
et chaque langue est une vision
différente du monde étant donné que
chaque l'or est une vision différente du
monde
les solutions pologne par exemple pour
le coc vides il y en a six ont
décentraliser le monde chaque peuple
donné sa solution peut-être différente
voyez c'est à dire je suis beau
l'indifférence et la différence
fonctionne avec le tout avec les langues
avec les peuples avec les cultures et
donc je dirais que la france et les
jacobine l'allemagne etc
elle a réussi à se décentraliser parce
qu'on lui a forcé la main au lieu des
vous et bientôt les ils marchent mieux
que la france pourquoi parce que la
france tout est sur paris et ses clients
et qu'aujourd'hui on aimerait bien qu'il
y ait du nouveau qui puisse sa palette
en occitanie par exemple à nice chez
vous par exemple on ne peut plus sortir
sans masque par exemple non à paris on
peut encore où je vous ai amené ça on
masque tout le temps mais moi je ramène
ça au nouveau le cil l'économie c'est
apparu à un moment donné c'est parce que
c'était le train coûtait trop cher entre
nice et paris
et donc ils sont restés sur le nice son
palais à paris et ils ont réussi à faire
quelque chose et on a dit l'école de
nice et d'écoles de nice est apparu un
peu parce qu'il y avait un éloignement
bon mais pas parce qu'ils étaient
occitan pas parce qu'ils balaient le
l'anc mais moi j'aurais voulu que la
langue ne rentre dedans
j'aurais voulu que les cuisines les
traditions quelle quelle que soit
qu'elles soient à la pluie venant
pourquoi toute cette des gens puissent
continuer à survivre à en apportant leur
nouveau ça c'est le seul nouveau que
j'accepte sinon à part ça les nouveaux
des artistes aujourd'hui qu'ils disent
mach et messieurs je fais des traits
bleus au lieu de fêtes de trévoux je
veux dv carré tout ça s'adresse moins
elle fait grave j'ai même dit des
bêtises vous allez dans les galeries
vous allez voir les nouvelles
expositions de valeo musée si j'ai pas
trop jaloux oui c'est un bon moteur
parti dans une vie non non la jalousie
c'est un très bon moteur ça marche la
géologie tu vois quelqu'un devait
déjeuner on se dit tiens mais adili
cette fois je vais essayer de faire
aussi bien que lui mais ça marche plus
c'est pour moi je suis plus jaloux les
plus être jaloux à 96 j'avais plus c'est
peut-être mon acte de qui j'étais jaloux
an dernier
je ne sais pas je pourrais pas vous dire
non le dernier un titre qui je suis
jaloux peut-être le catalogue de bernar
venet il est trop lourd il faut bien il
fait des sculptures très très lourde
très lourde
bernar venet les abats elles sont chères
et lourdes voilà là quand vous signez
ben uniquement ça c'est vous montrez
votre signature au fond oui c'est de mon
geste j'ai fait en ce moment une
exposition à la galerie guy pieters où
j'avais des prix des toiles de 85 81 et
gémit que le nom de père à ma manière
avec mon écriture du chant malevitch
kandinsky renoir et j'ai fait que le nom
de l'artiste pourquoi parce que à cause
que je noie son son ego et dans son nom
du chant sont égaux et là on va changer
ramener là son plus petit dénominateur
commun comment vous à l'école quand le
professeur vous lisez voilà les ramener
tout ça ou plus petit dénominateur
commun le plus petit dénominateur commun
on a c'est le nom de l'artiste qui veut
dire j'ai trouvé un style j'ai trouvé
ceci j'ai trouvé cela a convoyé le mont
mathis ça vous rappelle tout ce que m'a
dit ça fait qu'envoyer mon picasso sur
l'appel des femmes avec des yeux de
travers et cavret donc automatiquement
le nom est important donc ben aussi
c'était l'armée qu'une histoire d'ego
mais est ce que vous n'avez pas
l'impression que l'industrie du luxe
s'est inspiré de l'art justement dans ce
domaine puisque aujourd'hui la marque
est devenue très importante on a parfois
à sac où il ya la marque prend toute la
taille du sac ou toute la taille du
vêtement bah je le marque aujourd'hui la
civilisation en général en étant de 2020
et d'en prendre conscience
avec aussi les nouvelles technologies
avec avec avec l'intelligence
artificielle dont j'aime lady de mots
mais est en bonne conscience que le nom
elle même l'identité elle même devient
art devient elle même
je ne sais pas si je me suis bien
expliqué non oui sinon je me suis mal
expliqué on va recommencer mais je le
commence pas non mais j'ai j'allais dire
quelque chose
les lycéens maux de dents d'intelligence
artificielle intelligence artificielle
j'allais glisser ça là dedans parce que
je trouve que l'intelligence
artificielle
c'est entre autres les infos algorithmes
sont de ramasser des données des données
des données des données des données bon
enfant ce qu'on vous allez sortez de
l'ena ou comment sortais d'une école
auto école et que vous deviez un panty
fiant préfet et compagnie c'est parce
que j'ai eu beaucoup de données et vous
pourrez avoir le pouvoir à partir des
données que vous avez si on fait marcher
d'intelligence artificielle par rapport
à toutes les cultures qui est dans le
monde par rapport à tout ce qu'il ya
dans le monde et qu'on a un problème par
exemple prenons le problème du cachemire
cachemires un conflit au cachemire
l'intelligence artificielle vous
proposera une centaine de solutions
différentes entre autres la question y
at il un peuple cachemiri oui est-ce
qu'ils parlent de kashmiri oui à on ne
savait pas on croyait que c'était ou des
pakistanais ou des indiens non il ya un
peuple cachemiri est-ce qu'ils ont une
frontière linguistique oui si on leur
donnait cette frontière linguistique est
ce que ça fait de la paix au cachemire
louis donc bien la raison l'on côtoie
vivement l'intelligence artificielle que
je propose c'est un association qui
s'appelait cearà s e ra et sur lequel on
va pouvoir faire travailler
l'intelligence domisiel pour résoudre
les conflits ethniques et dans le monde
et c'est pour ça que je vous ai proposé
un petit livre je résous 80% des
conflits dans le monde
ah oui cette année c'est plus important
que d'un artiste peintre qui expose à
chamarande ah oui c'est vrai alors oui
je m'allonge qu'est ce que c'est je
m'allonge d'une d'un beau lieu c'est ses
centrales d'achat se montre son cul
après ça c'était ses vieux ça ça vous
montrez votre boutique au filet sur les
il ya 400 oeuvres à peu près au domaine
de chamarande elles sont à vous une
sorte des collections d'accueil amarante
une très belle expo c'est ma fille
mon petit fils qu'ils ont monté et qui
l'ont qu'ils ont pu quand même avis le
fait le catalogue est très beau
catalogue d'ailleurs réussi tout ça mais
c'est du ben déjà vu c'est du pet 527
rétrospective et c est ben du déjà vu
j'aurais voulu le nouveau ben le nouveau
ben il veut être ministre appelle
étrangères et bellevue régler le
problème du sahel qui veut brûler les
problèmes partout et où et quand
j'écoute les nouvelles et que je vous
vois à la télévision le soir je lève la
main en disant je voudrais intervenir je
voulais lui dire quelque chose
aussi vous êtes très bien parfois c'est
parfois je vous entends je me dis doit
vouloir ça veut dire et j'ai envie de
dire mon point de vue oui là par exemple
le liban à l'âge et des questions à me
poser un parce qu'il ya problème
l'effluent française elle est hélas
d'une conçu pas la france mais la langue
et tout arabe un moment donné c'est
l'arabe qui va donc si c'est une guerre
entre francophones et arabophones
il faut c'est différent de voir la
solution comme ça que de voir la
sélection en train de dire non je
envoyer des armes et je vais envoyer le
moment il faut enrayer dre je voulais
vous voyez vous avez noté aussi que
parfois on est dans nos frontières
linguistiques on parle tous la même
langue on est même source de la mi temps
mi temps des ondes de la même radio et
de l'internet a dit on n'a pas la rendre
nyon tous
on est tous dans nos frontières
linguistiques lesquels fonds d'origine
il pourrait la suisse moi j'ai vingt
tableaux qui serait le suisse n'existe
pas à les exposer au salon suisse a sévi
pourquoi parce que la suisse en réalité
yade francophone les amandes les noix et
des langues sont différentes
donc il ya une suisse avec plusieurs
langues qui disent que je voudrais une
rose que je faisais remarquer ce équipe
on peut être parler tous la même langue
et tous de la même origine ethnique et
ne pas avoir les mêmes les mêmes la même
religion par exemple il y avait le
religion je suis pas pour et donc ça ça
peut aussi être un moteur
d'affrontements dans l'aîné les régions
les religions cachent les ethnies
quand les irlandais se sont battus entre
eux en irlande
c'était parce que les irlandais se
mettait dans l'est
les églises catholique et les anglais se
mettaient dans les églises pour
l'instant donc la religion le s'élevait
d'alibi de pouvoir
ce qu'on veut conforter eux mêmes et ils
se comportaient même mais la religion
celle souvent se conforter lui même s'il
est le pôle mécanique disparaît la
langue disparaît lâche un peu stalinien
merci merci ben en tout cas être libre
l'exposition de l'ancien mène donc le
vieux ben c'est au domaine de chamarande
dans l'essonne jusqu'au 11 octobre
on va se retrouver juste après une pause
avec tom conan pour son roman radical
merci de m'avoir reçu c'était un blâme
au jour le gall souvent
[Musique]
comme conan vous avez 24 ans est publié
chez albin michel radical c'est votre
troisième roman la radicalisation
politique c'est un genre littéraire
dostoïevski jules vallès ou ernst von
salomone s'y sont essayés on ne marche
pas sur leurs traces sans trembler
qu'est ce qui vous a décidé alors moi et
fillon je voulais pas parler forcément
de la radicalisation au départ giral
intention c'était d'écrire plutôt une
histoire d'amour sous une forme de
contamination pas de contamination au
sens épidémiologique me sucer qu'on
parle beaucoup de ça en ce moment
mais au sens vraiment voilà de l'amour
en tant que phénomène qui nous
assaillent de lire dans une forme assez
total un peu comme ce que dit alain
badiou d'ailleurs en parlant de
processus de vérité au sujet de l'amour
est en fait cette contamination en
l'occurrence va emmener le personnage
dans le narrateur très très loin jusqu'à
effectivement accepté un peu
l'impossible et nuit même pas forcément
à se radicaliser mais en tout cas
effectivement avoir des accointances et
des rapprochements de plus en plus
intense avec cette personne qui est
pourtant normalement son son antithèse
donc c'est vraiment une contamination
amoureuse qui effectivement fait glisser
la personne est aussi un peu la société
c'est vrai ce que c'est aussi une
métaphore politique vers vers la
radicalisation c'est vrai que c'est
l'histoire d'anne étudiants de sciences
po qui tombe amoureux d'un jeune gay de
18 ans lui même radicalisé et qui quand
même
quoique vous le disiez se radicalise son
contact
oui c'est à dire que effectivement je
pense que le vrai problème c'est que au
point de départ le narrateur c'est
vraiment un personnage parisien on
pourrait dire assez ordinaire je veux
dire qu'il n'est ni très à droite est
très à gauche il est plutôt au centre
gauche
il tend quand même vers une forme voilà
un peu plus socialisante et c'est
uniquement parce qu'il a la chance pour
ce n'est pas seulement la caricature
mais parce que voilà il a bon quand même
dans je veux dire le sens d'une certaine
justice sociale voilà il veut quand même
améliorer les choses et donc il a quand
même plutôt des accointances avec la
gauche
mais en fait dès le départ il était
lui-même un peu dégoûté parce que en
fait être de gauche pour un étudiant à
sciences po parisiens même dans
l'univers contemporain qui paie même pas
mal chamboulé idéologiquement
finalement ça reste quelque chose
d'assez convenu et en fait il a envie d'
aventure c'est un peu la tragédie qui
valent qui va laisser dire dès le départ
il a envie d'aventuré effectivement ce
personnage d'harry qui lui donc est
proche des gilets jaunes et avec des
opinions politiques très très très très
différente de celle qui peut avoir sa le
fascine parce qu'effectivement c'est
différent ces nouveaux branchements ben
par khaled la question de la nouveauté
balla c'est exactement ça c'est quelque
chose de nouveau et je dirais que c'est
une emprise qui va être à la fois
corporelle immédiate affective puisqu'il
ya vraiment la question de la
fascination physique évidemment arrivé
est très jeune il est très beau donc on
est on est tout de suite tenté enfin en
tout cas pour une personne homosexuelle
on peut parfaitement se mettre dans la
poule à pau du narrateur et ensuite on
est prêts à accepter tout et y compris
cette tentation cette tentation radical
on pourrait dire qu'il n'est pas
seulement celle du narrateur je pense
que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
finalement est une sorte une sorte de
possibilités en fait ce que j'ai voulu
décrire c'est pas seulement une
trajectoire subjective identifiait
anecdotique
c'est en fait une sorte de risque c'est
une espèce de risque que je perçois que
je percevais d'ailleurs avant d'écrire
le livre c'est un peu ce qui m'a
effectivement donner cette impulsion
c'est que je perds ce dès qu'il y avait
ce risque là un risque je trouve
mortifère que je trouve un peu voilà un
peu terrifiant mais qui est réel parce
qu'en fait ils touchent là en
l'occurrence dans le livre je parle
beaucoup de la radicalisation à
l'extrême droite avec une sorte de
contamination comme je le disais mais en
fait cette tentation radical
elle touche plein de milieu et elle
touche on pourrait dire la jeunesse en
général la jeunesse française
la jeunesse européenne la jeunesse
occidentale et peut-être même d'autres
jeunesse que je connais sans doute moins
parce que finalement on se rend compte
dans les dernières années que si on fait
une petite rétrospective rapide on voit
que finalement bas à gauche il ya dans
la jeunesse une tentation de voter non
pas pour le ps etc
mais pour franz insoumise par exemple à
droite c'est va être beaucoup plus
le rassemblement national que les
républicains chez les écolos ont ici
également que dans la jeunesse pas
seulement mais notamment il ya des
mouvements aussi comme extinction
rébellion par exemple on a pas mal parlé
de les quelques derniers mois qui est
une forme radicale vraiment avec du
happening avec vraiment une volonté un
peu d'en découdre sur le terrain du
combat écologiste
il ya aussi vous pourrez dire des
radicaux avec tous les guillemets con
con qu'on peut qu'on peut mettre dans
les mouvements féministes dans les
mouvements indigéniste et c'est donc en
fait c'est un mouvement un peu général
en l'occurrence la focale elle est sûre
ce glissement qui est peut-être le plus
perceptible le plus évident est
peut-être aussi le plus effrayant c'est
à dire la radicalisation fléchissement
tout crypto fasciste dans la société
européenne avec une honte est incroyable
d'aider populisme et de cette tentation
radical encore une fois mais ça touche
je pense la société en général et
pourquoi la jeunesse parce que
finalement pourquoi est ce qu'elle est
intéressante c'est que je pense que la
jeunesse elle est dans une projection et
s'il ya cette tentation radical qui
touchent plus précisément la jeunesse -
les couches un peu plus âgés un peu plus
insérés dans la société c'est aussi
parce qu'il a plus de projections il ya
plus de projections et et je pense que
des personnes aujourd'hui qui qui sont
indépendamment de la crise du coc vide
et c'est à qui on a rajouté
effectivement une couche en terme de
difficulté de projection social d'emploi
etc
mais indépendamment de sa aujourd'hui on
n'a plus de repères connus on a plus de
perspective professionnelle évidente on
sait que les études elle même d'ailleurs
c'est marrant ben a parlé de beaucoup
d'aspects que moi qui m'intéresse
beaucoup
par exemple l'intelligence artificielle
pour prendre juste cet exemple là
effectivement on perçoit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui je parle pas d'eux dans
dix ans dans 20 ans mais aujourd'hui en
2020 les processus d'automatisation avec
l' influence de l'intelligence
artificielle dégâts femmes etc et
également de leurs équivalents aussi
asiatiques vont aller dans un sens de
destructions d'emplois on sait
qu'aujourd'hui a beaucoup de tâches qui
vont être automatisés il ya beaucoup de
tâches qui ne vont plus effectuées par
des humains en tout cas part de moins en
moins d'humains et ça en fait la
jeunesse elle le perçoit très bien elle
ne passe très bien je dirais elle même
elle utilise toute la journée des outils
extrêmement sophistiquée avec des
smartphones qui peuvent faire de plus en
plus de
choses et dont on sait que finalement
demain on pourra peut-être transposer
des intelligences c'est vraiment ce que
disait ben tout à l'heure je trouve ça
passionnant et on pourrait les
transposer en quelques fractions de
secondes et finalement nous sur comment
dire dépassé en termes de performances
intellectuelles pour résoudre un tas de
problèmes
vous prenez n'importe quel domaine
possible peut-être part peut-être pas
l'art d'ailleurs c'est peut-être aussi
peut être pour ça que c'est peut-être
une forme qui reste intéressante mais
voilà c'est une vraie menace
et tous ces phénomènes là et cette
absence de perspective réelle est vécue
de manière assez traumatisante par cette
jeunesse qui donc peut basculer dans la
radicalisation mais alors justement tom
konan votre héros lui il a beau être
homosexuel juif éduqué il fait sciences
po vous même je crois que vous avez fait
hec il et il aime les films de
desplechin est il à voter mélenchon en
2017 et en dépit de tout cela il peut
passer de la lutte des classes à la
lutte des races en un clin d'oeil au
fond oui alors en un clin d'oeil c'est
vrai là en tout cas dans le livre c'est
en un clin d'oeil je pense que peut-être
dans la réalité serait d'être un peu
plus compliqué qu'il faudrait quand même
des ressorts un peu psychologique et un
disons un terrain on pourrait dire
favorable pour permettre ce genre de
développement aussi rapide
c'est un peu une version accélérée
néanmoins je pense que c'est tout à fait
probable
on sait que l'alliance rouge brune comme
on l'appelle parfois elle est très
redouté je pense qu'aujourd'hui elle
n'est pas forcément immédiate au sens là
de ce qui va se passer forcément par
exemple en 2022 en france mais en
revanche c'est quelque chose qu'on
perçoit par exemple dans le si on prend
un phénomène qu'on observe tous les
jours sur les réseaux sociaux et même
d'ailleurs dans les relations hier lé
nouvel iphone dans la réalité c'est le
complotisme il ya du complotisme
aujourd'hui qui touchent à peu près
toutes les questions politiques et
toutes les questions d'actu possible que
ce soit le coronavirus la crise
financière l'intervention de telles
puissances au moyen-orient etc
il ya du complotisme à tous les étages
et se complotisme bas
il est à mon avis sans doute l'un des
artefacts l'une des manifestations de
cette tentation la de ce glissement là
qui effectivement enfin auquel personne
n'échappe
on pourrait dire un taxi qui sont parus
récemment sur ces phénomènes le
conspirationnisme mais c'est vrai on le
retrouve à peu près dans toutes les
catégories de la population d'ailleurs
même les antilles conspirationnistes
sont devenus conspirationnistes il y en
a pour servir toutes les causes
moi ce qui ce qui m'étonne mai mais
c'est le sujet de votre livre aussi
c'est comment on peut passer au fond
d'un camp où on se croyait on sait bien
que les opinions politiques qu'on les a
depuis on est on est formé pour les habs
avoir sa dépendent nos parents de notre
milieu de l'époque dans laquelle on est
tous à nous façonnent politiquement et
un moment on peut tout oublier et passer
à autre chose sous l'affluence au fond
d'un épiderme de quelqu'un qui nous
plaît qui nous excite oui alors c'est un
épiderme en effet mais c'est aussi je le
disais tout à l'heure sur alain badiou
qui parle de processus de vérité pour
parler de l'amour
il dit que ces processus de vérité c'est
des vérités qui sont universels infinie
et absolue et je pense qu'il faut le
prendre vraiment au pied de la lettre
l'expérience de l'amour c'est une
expérience absolue et j'ai voulu
vraiment dans tout cas la trajectoire du
générateur nicolas expliquer ce
phénomène là donc effectivement ça peut
être l'un des biens et pourquoi en fait
je les choisis parce que en termes de
procédés narratifs ça permet tout
simplement de se reconnaître n'importe
qui peut faire l'expérience de l'amour
on peut tomber amoureux là en venant au
studio j'aurais pu tomber amoureux de
quelqu'un dans un café j'ai pris un coca
juste avant de venir voilà et peut-être
que j'aurais été embarqués dans une
expérience très nouvelle pour moi
en rupture avec les valeurs et vous
savez l'heure de jeu lorsque le ton père
ne vous hâtez vous avez l'air de dire
qu'on peut tomber amoureux de n'importe
qui donne là en l'occurrence votre héros
tombe amoureux d'un conspirationnistes
et ne plus tôt ignorant raciste jaloux
en plus c'est violent on se dit c'est
beaucoup pour pour un garçon
plutôt bobo même s'il déteste les bobos
parce que c'est la mode mais il est
plutôt au beau et tout à coup il va
tomber amoureux de tout ça à la fois
encore une fois ouais c'est vrai mais
encore une fois c'est la conjonction de
plusieurs éléments c'est le terrain
individuel le terrain subjectif avec
effectivement l'expérience de l'amour et
le terrain social encore une fois est en
fait ce terrain soit on voit bien qu en
fait dès le départ le narrateur lui-même
à une désespérance dire que à la fois il
veut continuer on pourrait dire le rêve
méritocratique républicain faire des
bonnes études s'insérer
professionnellement peut-être aller dans
la fonction publique intègre et voilà le
service de l'état cameroun d une
fonction des plus nobles en france va
considérer comme étant très noble voire
même peut-être l'engagement politique
etc
on voit que c'est tout à fait le voilà
le genre de perspectives auxquelles le
narrateur nicolas aurait pu être
voilà présenté dans son avenir proche
mais en fait il n'y croit plus et tout
le problème c'est que ce rêve là en fait
est un rêve qui se fissure qui se firent
sfi sur chaque jour parce qu'en fait on
n'est plus dans une situation où on peut
comment dire concrétiser ces valeurs là
ces valeurs là elles sont abstraites
elles sont peut-être très bien fichu je
veux dire c on sait par exemple qu'il ya
des modèles comme ça qu'on social comme
par exemple la constitution de la
troisième république non par la
concision pardon de 19,93 pardon qui n'a
jamais été en application avec des
déclarations de valeur
absolument fantastique on s'en gargarise
comme ça parce qu'effectivement c'est
tellement tentant d'avoir une vision
très égalitaire qui est à la fois très
progressiste pour les femmes extérieurs
tout ça est très très bien mais en fait
on se rend bien compte tenu de l'écart
abyssal et peut-être même de plus en
plus abyssal qui existe entre ces
valeurs là entre ces principes entre ses
idéaux et la réalité la réalité elle se
fracasse contre ces déclarations de
valeur à l'emporte-pièce quand quelqu'un
nous paraissent est à l'emporte-pièce
même si elles ont été longuement mûrie
et c'est aujourd'hui on est plus dans
dans cet épisode il s'agit de faire
matures et les choses là il faut qu'il y
ait une sorte de concrétisation de ces
choses là et en fait on tout simplement
on y croit plus alors en l'occurrence
effectivement le personnage de
nicolas da basculé alors qu'ils
pensaient peut-être un peu préservé de
cela parce que lui-même il ya en fait
qu'il n'est pas préservée et ce
glissement du terrain pour revenir à
votre question du terrain social vers le
terrain identitaire et raciale je pense
qu'en fait c'est typiquement c'est le
risque le plus le plus élevé on pouvait
dire c'est aussi pour ça qui m'a
intéressé mais je pense que c'est
quelque chose de possible sans vouloir
faire de comparaisons absurde avec avec
la chronique avec des épisodes
historiques mais bon dans les années 30
on sait bien que c'est quand même aussi
une perspective sociale extrêmement
compliqué et une crise sociale à
proprement parler de chômage etc qui
ensuite a fait que des personnes ont pu
après se reconnaître dans un discours
ouvertement fascistes qui a donné le
lait régime qu'on connaît en europe
donc effectivement je pense qu'on n'est
jamais très loin de ça il s'agit pas de
brandir la voilà le spectre de cette
menace en disant regardez le fasciste ou
bornes au coin de la rue c'est pas ça du
tout est en quelque sorte j'ai voulu me
dépasser ça parce que c'est il faut
actualiser cette cette peur et il faut à
peu aller au delà
tellement elle nous est rabâché de
manière comme ça un peu bête
néanmoins ce risque il est il est quand
même réel et en fait je pense que
pourquoi ce glissement il est possible
tant pour le personnage de nicolas mais
pour disons une société de manière un
peu plus générale parce qu'en fait il ya
une négativité
il ya une sorte de négativité qui en
fait est la frustration encore une fois
cet écart entre ses déclarations de
valeur c'est cette idée aux républicains
et hélas hélas la réalité de l'insertion
professionnelle des inégalités très
importantes qui peuvent exister dans la
société etc et donc on peut glisser
effectivement pour investir d'une
certaine façon cette frustration
cette négativité c'est un truc quasi
quasi freudien quasi psychanalytique
on investit dans quelque chose donc si
on ne peut plus si entre guillemets là
le combat social n'est plus suffisant
donc entre guillemets si voter mélenchon
c'est pas suffisant ça donne pas de
résultats concrets
effectivement il ya un risque que
ensuite dans ce disque bombe à quelque
part et ses propos qu on entend
finalement assez souvent
bon bah j'ai essayé mélenchon prochaine
fois bon d'être testé le front national
par le rassemblement national qui n'en
n'est qu'un prolongement
parce que voilà finalement peut-être
voir ce qui est encore plus radical et
c'est donc en fait on voit bien que
habituellement où il ya une tentation
radical j'insiste vraiment là-dessus
elle peut prendre toutes les formes
possibles et encore une fois le
complotisme on en parlait tout à l'heure
le complotisme autres tout départ quand
on regarde certaines vidéos complotistes
à proprement parler est vraiment
terrifiante en termes d'effet sur les
psychés un individuelles et collectives
au tout départ vous prenez une vidéo
compositionnel partout sur tous les
réseaux sociaux par exemple même
ailleurs baotou départ vous écoutez de
trois minutes vous êtes séduit
effectivement il ya de la corruption
effectivement il ya des grandes
puissances
effectivement il ya des inégalités il ya
de la pauvreté effectivement il ya des
la corruption financière au plus haut
niveau et c'est donc au début on est
séduit exactement comme le personnage de
nicolas au départ et séduit et ensuite
après on se rend compte et c'est
vraiment ce glissement cette
contamination progressive qui va être
celle du narrateur avec effectivement le
la passion amoureuse par ailleurs qui va
évidemment enclenché et accélérer
phénomène mais on voit bien qu'en fait
on adhère de plus en plus mais en fait
qu'est-ce que c'est assez la dynamique
de la dynamique de la négativité
on veut vraiment investir encore une
fois cette frustration là le fait que
notre vie sera pas la hauteur de nos
attentes
et donc voilà il ya ce risque là où des
bus on déteste l'économie par exemple on
va détester de commerce détester la
finance un qui va être aussi l'un des
objets un petit peu dans lequel on va
investir cette haine entre guillemets et
puis après finalement on va la
généraliser et après qu'est ce que c'est
finalement le fascisme le crypto
fascisme la tentation d'extrême droite
sans viser des personnes est parti en
particulier
c'est en fait une vision de and global
on pourrait dire alors que les radicaux
sectorielles sont beaucoup plus
inoffensif on pourrait dire vous avez
parlé de la menthe et l'arrêt des
localisations en général pas seulement à
l'extrême droite il ya une
radicalisation à l'extrême gauche et une
radicalisation chez les écologistes chez
certains écologistes pas tous est ce que
vous voyez là même radicalisation
alors du côté j'allais dire des
centristes
c'est à dire qu'au fond face au gilet
jaune puisque votre livre il ya comme
arrière-plan
le mouvement des philippines est-ce que
face aux jets les jo nous avez vu la
montée d'une rade
égalisation équivalentes de la part des
centristes des des macros nice des
tenants du pouvoir d des patrons d ouais
alors c'est intéressant je voyais pas
les choses comme ça mais effectivement
il ya des lois il ya une expression qui
résume un peu ça c'est l'extrême centre
est effectivement l'extrême centre est
une forme radicale du centrisme on
pourrait dire alors après il s'agit pas
de mettre radicalisation à toutes les
sauces mais effectivement on pourrait
dire qu'en effet ce que je disais tout à
l'heure sur le fait qu'on il ya des
déclarations des proclamations de droit
d'objectif on sait que les organisations
internationales elle même et met sans
cesse des normes
voilà reconnaissent des droites c'est
parce qu'évidemment très bien avec
entendu il s'agit pas de remettre en
cause cela s'est très bien qui est un
état de droit qu'ils soient assis sur du
droit positif et le droit mou si comme
le disait universitaire delmas marty
donc tout ça c'est très bien mais
effectivement il peut y avoir un écueil
qui est le fait en réalité 2 1 et cogne
un peu positiviste on pourrait dire de
dire finalement pas le droit c'est le
bien et donc il suffit de rajouter des
droits de modifier la constitution de
rajouter des traités de faire en sorte
que l'union européenne reconnaisse
elle-même des droits on sait qu'il ya
une déclaration spécifique des droits il
y avait là il ya une profusion de droit
de normes de garantie etc
évidemment toute la difficulté c'est la
réalité sociale parce que la réalité
sociale et pas seulement sociale à la
réalité juridictionnelle mais également
sociale passe carrément des
effectivement l'égalité des droits et la
liberté de faire un certain nombre de
choses si on veut pas les exercer dans
dans la concrétude de l'existence ça n'a
évidemment aucun sens oui il y assemble
d'une fille une forme de radicalisation
qui prend des formes beaucoup plus
abstraite beaucoup plus idéologique mais
en effet par par idéologie
on peut aussi faire taire va votre
émission s'appelle interdit d'interdire
c'est quand même pas non plus pour rien
par idéologie et sans les armes
on peut également effectivement faire
taire des gens des collectifs et des
mouvements entier fusse-t-il
démocratique comme conan tous les
écrivains qui ont écrit sur le la
radicalisation se sont radicalisées eux
mêmes à un moment ou un autre de leur
vie vous est ce que vous sentez
radicaliser aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
ressemblez à l'un de vos deux héros non
non non vraiment c'est un c'est bien un
roman même si c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
comme une difficulté parfois pour les
gens de comprendre que le narrateur
n'est pas n'est pas l'auteur narrateur
c'est un narrateur et donc c'était un
personnage
après il peut y avoir évidemment des
éléments mois que j'ai pu observer parce
qu'effectivement c'est une forme d'
enquête et il ya des éléments du fis
demandant mon existence qui ont pu
effectivement faire écho avec la cendre
de situations et de scènes qui sont
décrites dans le livre
non moi même je me vois absolument pas
comme étant victime comme étant en phase
de contamination enfin je pense qu'il ya
d'autres types de contamination qui sont
plus à redouter actuellement mais non
j'ai voulu en revanche étudié de manière
très claire quelque chose qui entre
guillemets dans mon entourage et ça par
contre c'est réalise est réel dans mon
entourage immédiat dans le milieu dans
les milieux que je fréquente puisque
d'autres on fréquente tous des mieux
puisque d'autres je veux dire dire si on
est charpentier on va fréquenter des
charpentiers si on est dans la mode on
va fréquenter les gens dans la mode et
c'est pour moi l'un des milieux dans
lesquels je traîne c'est le milieu
homosexuel même si ça veut rien dire
mais disons des milieux ou des
applications aujourd'hui beaucoup tout
simplement ou voilà on se rencontre
également par ce biais là
et donc j'ai constaté c'était un peu là
l'une des prémisses et un peu le destine
qui faisaient qu'ils avaient vraiment
que ce soit intéressant écrire dessus
c'était que ça touchait des milieux
nouveau s'est pas complètement nouveau
un gem lui il ya quelques temps un
article dans slate qui expliquait qu'il
y avait chez les homosexuels une
tendance à voter à droite à l'extrême
droite c'est donc ce n'est pas
complètement nouveau je n'ai pas inventé
l'eau tiède
néanmoins c'est un phénomène je pense
qu'ils se développent pas dire
qu'aujourd'hui il ya vraiment dans la
jeunesse homosexuels qui sera forcément
comme tel de fayt lez dans ces pratiques
qui à 18 ans 20 ans 25 ans 30 ans etc
qui ouvertement favorable aux idées du
rassemblement national même
indépendamment de ce parti il s'agit pas
de zoom et spécialement sur une partie a
basculé
mais disons des thèses qui qui sont des
thèses voilà ostensiblement complotistes
crypto fasciste voire même carrément
fascisante
donc c'est un c'est un vrai risque que
j'ai observé et contrairement à ce qu'on
peut croire encore une fois ça peut
toucher des milieux très différents et
c'est là parce que ont eu vent des
grandes écoles parce qu'on est
homosexuel parce qu'on est de telle et
telle catégorie que c'est une quelconque
garantie contre contre ce naufrage
contre ce cette tentation
c'est aussi un roman sur sur
l'homosexualité effectivement vous dites
d'ailleurs eu donc l'acte sexuel est
plus fort entre hommes que entre hétéros
pourquoi oui alors ça c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est le narrateur qui le dira
encore une fois le narrateur lui lui
même je dois vous le murray me réfugier
toujours derrière ça mais bon un moment
donné c'est vrai que le narrateur
lui-même a une vision très radicale de
sa propre sexualité parce
qu'effectivement ils salissent à être un
peu dans le ton est donc en effet il est
il est hideux en fait au tout début
c'est un peu comme dans le film fight
club je sais pas si vous voyez avec de
david fincher avec brad pitt et edward
norton qui est inspiré d'un livre de
chuck palahniuk qui s'appelle également
fight club et où en fait il ya le
personnage dont je parle du film parce
que les gens connaissent mieux je pense
d'edward norton qui en fait tu vas
fantasmer le personnage de brad pitt qui
en fait son antithèse
c'est à dire que norton il est sec brad
pitt il est costaud norton il n'est pas
hyper beau brad pitt idée très beau
gosse norton il est comptable d'un
boulot très chiant brad pitt ils veulent
des bagnoles
les il a l'air d'avoir une vie super
coup de vis dans une grande baraque
apple street
et donc voilà donc c'est un petit peu ça
il fallait que le narrateur lui même au
début c'est quelqu'un qui a l'air un peu
emmerdant magnificience comme cela que
j'ai une chance qu sont spécialement
détestable c'est pas le problème mais
viril fait six ans où il allait être un
étudiant en sciences po complètement
ordinaire il est centre gauche qui se
prépare à un truc genre concours
administratifs pas de problème mais je
veux dire il n'a aucune espèce
d'originalité enfin c'est un personnage
qui a l'air peine relativement shihan ou
en tout cas encore une fois ordinaire
comme un 10 on est donc finalement il va
vouloir dans les différents aspects de
sa vie de sa de ses idées également
effectivement pas un peu faire
l'expérience de toute chose vous pourrez
dire comme rimbaud lisait faire
l'expérience de toute chose avec son
corps lui c'est avec son corps avec ses
idées etc
il a même abandonné sans vouloir rentrer
dans des choses trop trop trop explicite
mais a abandonné même par exemple je
sais pas si je peux préciser ce point
mais dans la communauté homosexuelle
il ya beaucoup deviennent partition
entre les actifs et les passifs les gens
iront chercher ce que ça signifie et au
début du texte
le narrateur il est évidemment actifs
parce qu'évidemment il ne s'assume pas
complètement comme homosexuel et à la
fin sans vouloir spoiler trop mais bon
peu importe il est passif et il aime ça
parce que voilà un moment donné
effectivement il veut aller jusqu'au
bout de l'expérience la même manière que
idéologiquement il veut aller jusqu'au
bout de l'expérience donc ce n'est pas
encore une fois le livre n'est pas avoir
comme étant une sorte de manuel c'est
même sort un antimanuel mais c'est un
glissement ont décrit un glissement que
ça n'existait pas de de rajouter de la
moraline
à chaque page pour dire disclaimer
attention les gars ne fait pas ça c'est
des conseillers non il s'agissait
d'aller d'aller au bout du processus
c'est pour ça que le roman a mon avis tu
as un instrument de connaissance très
intéressant parce que on peut en tout
cas c'est très puissant potentiellement
après le réussi ou pas ça c'est autre
chose
et parce que futur on peut aller très
très loin 1 cet été un essai évidemment
ça va pas été aussi loin puisque ça
correspond pas voilà forcément moi même
à ma philosophie de la chose donc voila
et je dirais que ensuite quelqu'un qui
avait dit ça c'était un un auteur dont
qui est assez controversé qui s'appelle
guillaume dustan donc et qui est décédé
il avait dit ça je crois dans une
émission me semble qu'effectivement la
relation homosexuelle physique pouvait
être plus forte que la relation
hétérosexuelle
il n'y a pas d'explication autre que
cela mais après je rend à césar ce qui
est à césar
je savais qu'il avait dit dans paris
dernière à l'époque guillaume dustan
c'était cette date d'organisation et il
m'avait dit ça c'est d'accord abbas m
c'est effectivement voilà c est ce que
c'est quelqu'un qui avait été très très
loin dans cette vision après je pense
que lui là dessus mais plus directement
parce qu'il avait après mis en avant
d'autres éléments comme le bar backing
n'est pas du tout quelque chose que je
que je recommande que je conseille qui
que ce soit mais maintenant je pense que
tout le monde pense que sa sexualité
toujours les plus fortes que celles des
voisins c'est ça doit être assez humain
après tout ouais merci comme ryan ouais
merci il ya les mots oui non non mais je
voulais juste préciser / / / dustan
qu'en réalité le le comment dire
l'expérience romanesque je pense que
c'est aussi l'expérience du corps et
c'est pas seulement qu'on ne pourrait
croire l'expérience des idées et le fait
de lire je pense que lire c'est aussi
une transposition il ya un grand travail
de d'imagination qui est fait par un
lecteur d'avoir un lecteur brûle plus de
cadeaux qu'elle calories qu'on y lit un
livre pour qu'ils regardent une émission
par exemple c'est beaucoup moins passifs
sans mauvais jeu de mots donc il ya
aussi voit la question du corps elle est
aussi à retrouver dans l'expérience de
l'écriture elle-même et de la lecture
merci thomas conan je rappelle que
radical est votre troisième roman et qui
vient de paraître chez albin michel
je rappelle également que être libre la
grande exposition de ben a lieu au
domaine de chamarande dans l'essonne
jusqu'au 11 octobre merci de nous avoir
suivis rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]